now I want to talk today about one small
thing before we move on to signaling
because it really kind of completes the
work that we talked about with respect
to trafficking so I popped this question
up last time and if it seemed like there
weren't quite enough sort of people
leaping to give me an answer but let's
just take a look at the big picture of
things as it's always good to do because
this will also get me to one other topic
which is protein misfolding so at the
end of the day what really defines where
a protein is what it does is defined by
its sequence but you always want to
remember that a protein sequence is
defined by its messenger the messenger
is defined by the pre messenger
yes there may be splicing events that
really cause changes in localization but
the pre messenger includes the content
and then what defines that is the DNA
there's certain aspects of regulation
the epigenetic level that we don't talk
about barely in this course but I want
you to make to make sure that you
realize at the end of the day what the
protein is how its faults is defined
originally by the sequence of the DNA
although a long way along here the post
translational modifications that we
started talking about last time
are defined by the protein sequence
which all the way is defined by the DNA
so so much of protein function and
there's one more aspect of proteins
that's defined by the DNA sequence and
that's whether a protein folds well or
perhaps in MIT in some cases Mis folds
and that's the thing I want to talk
about very briefly today because I think
that this captures the picture so let's
just go over here and write in this
folded proteins
which just like everything else largely
end up being dictated by the DNA because
whether a protein folds faithfully into
a good structure or Mis folds can be a
function of the protein sequence so
there could be mutations in the protein
that ultimately end up that the protein
miss fold and forms either a misfolded
tertiary structure or even worse adopts
an aggregated form that causes a lot of
damage within cells and outsides of
cells so I want to talk just briefly
about the processes that we have it's
just one slide to deal with miss folded
proteins so when a protein is translated
it almost starts folding straight away
especially large proteins a fair amount
of a protein may have already emerged
from the ribosome and started folding
even when the whole protein isn't made
the sequence ultimately ends you up with
a well folded protein but if the protein
does not fold fast enough or there is a
mistake in this which might be caused
intrinsically by the primary sequence if
there's a mistake in that so slow
folding or incorrect folding then you
will end up with a protein that's
partially folded within the context of a
cell we especially encounter miss folded
proteins when we are over expressing
proteins in cells because you're just
making one of a type of protein really
quickly and it doesn't have a chance to
adopt its faithful structure so there
are proteins within the cell that help
sort of protect the folding process
early on to allow the protein to have
enough time in singular not with a lot
of copies of itself around that a miss
folded to adopt a folded structure and
these proteins are called chaperones
I don't know what if you guys are
familiar with the term chaperone it was
a term that was heavily used in the sort
of 18th and 19th century a chaperone
used to be an aunt or someone who you
would send out with your beautiful young
daughter to chaperone her to protect her
so she didn't get bothered by those mean
men out there so chaperones were that
was the original definition of the
chaperone and it's kind of interesting
that the chaperones are now proteins
that help folding or protect against
miss folding how do they do this
generally a protein will fold poorly if
it's very very if it's quite hydrophobic
and hydrophobic patches are exposed and
aggregate so let's say you have a
protein and there's a lot of copies but
they're not salted if you have things
that are hydrophobic that would normally
end up tucked inside the protein if the
protein hasn't folded in its good time
these will just start to form aggregates
sort of associating with each other it's
just a physical phenomenon if you put
something that's got a lot of
hydrophobic faces on the outside this
will start forming an aggregated bundle
and not a nicely folded protein at all
what the chaperones may do is in part
hold the partially folded protein so
let's just think of this big jelly bean
as a chaperone until things start to
adopt a favorable state but sometimes
it's just too much the chaperone cannot
handle the flux of protein so the
protein ends up being recognized as miss
folded and then it gets tagged as a Miss
folded protein and it gets taken to a
place
and the cell for disposal so if you're
unable to fold there is a tagging
process and I mentioned it last time
it's a process known as ubiquitination
this is also a post translational
modification but it's one that occurs on
poorly folded proteins and I'm going to
describe to you that system because the
ubiquitination is the flag the signal or
the tag to take this protein to the
great shredder basically and so what
does the once a paper shredder think I
like the analogy with a paper shredder
so here's a fellow he's got too much on
his in his inbox so he just sends it
straight to the shredder it's a little
bit about too much misfolded protein
being made so you instead of sort of
waiting to deal with the paperwork you
just send it straight to the shredder
and the proteasome is the cellular
shredder that actually breaks proteins
up into small chunks and then digests
them out so think of the proteasome is a
shredder which chops up proteins into
small pieces mostly into short peptides
that are eight to fourteen amino acids
in length fairly small short peptides
won't cause a problem in aggregation and
will then be further digested now if
you've got this shredder sitting around
in the cell it's like having you know a
paper shredder on all the time you got
it there's a risk things may end up in
there without meaning to be so for
things to be tagged for shredding they
go through what's known as the ubiquitin
systems so the first thing to get into
that is
and it's only then that proteins are
tagged for shredding up or chopping up
by the proteasome so as you can sort of
tell by its name it's not protease
function but it's a large macromolecular
protease with lots and lots of subunits
that are important to cut that
polypeptide into smaller pieces but but
because many of your proteins may be
partially folded or mis folded they
first have to be unfolded so the
ubiquitin is the signal to send proteins
to the proteasome where the second
action is protease activity and the
first action is unfolding so what I show
you on this picture is the the Barrell
structure of a protease own let me
explain the components of it the red
component of the proteasome is a multi
Marik ring that uses ATP and starts
tugging apart the protein the protein
that you need to destroy but it will
only do that if the protein becomes
labeled for destruction by the ubiquitin
system and I am showing you here a
massively simplified version let's say
this is a mis folded protein it gets
tagged with another protein it's a
really little protein known as ubiquitin
I've shown you the three-dimensional
structure here and using ATP you end up
managing to put a ubiquitin chain on the
protein that's going to be destroyed
that is a post translational
modification that is a tagging for
destruction if the protein is not tagged
then it's not going to be chewed up that
makes sense you don't want to
desperately be chopping up proteins in a
Cell with with wild abandon
once the ubiquitin chain is on here the
protein will bind to the unfold days
part of the proteasome and with ATP was
just start tugging the rest of the
residual structure apart
to thread the protein down into the blue
part of the barrel it's a little hard to
see it like this but it's literally the
proteasome are four concentric rings let
me see my artwork is gonna be good
enough well that's an unfolding and so
is that and then in the center there is
a protease and each of these components
is multimeric having six or seven
subunits so it's a huge structure it is
has a sedimentation coefficient of 20s
that entire structure I don't know if
you remember when I talked about
ribosomes they were so big we didn't
tend to talk about them by size we could
talked about them by sedimentation
coefficient and the large and small
subunits of the ribosome the eukaryotic
one just to remind you before T s and
60s so just remember that S stands for
sped works sped burg it's a
sedimentation coefficient unit it is
describes how fast a protein
precipitates so once the protein has
been labeled with ubiquitin it binds to
the unfold ace and then the single
strand feeds into the center core which
is two sections of protease so it's
feeding in here
it sees the protease activity and then
it's just short pieces of protein spit
out of the proteasome once these are
really little pieces of peptide they're
readily digested by proteases within the
cell and you can recycle the amino acids
or you can do other things with these
small pieces of peptide they actually
end up sometimes being sent for
presentation on this
Offices of the cell by the immune system
and you may hear a little bit more about
that later so the the proteasome I
apologize this should have been 26 has a
molecular weight that's very large 2000
kilo daltons that's why we refer it to
it by its sedimentation coefficient so
this machinery is very important to get
rid of miss folded or aggregated
proteins to destroy them now there's n
isn't a people aware of the sorts of
diseases that can result from miss
folded proteins it's anyone been reading
the news much about certain types of
diseases particularly in neurobiology
anyone aware of those yeah which one yes
mad cows so there are a variety of
neurological disorders a mad cow is one
of them right New Jersey spelled Jakob
but Alzheimer's disease is another one
picks disease is another there are a
wide variety of neurological disorders
the results from misfolded proteins both
inside the cell and in the extracellular
matrix forming these tangles that are
toxic to the neurons causing them to no
longer function and then resulting in
many of these neurological disorders the
ones I've described to you I've
mentioned to you here I know many of you
are familiar with Alzheimer's disease
mad cow disease is a variant of a
particular protein misfolding disease
that was first noted in cattle and they
basically just fell down dropped down
and it was in some cases ascribed to the
contagion with the disease is ascribed
not to a virus or to a microorganism but
literally to misfolded proteins causing
the formation of more misfolded proteins
so these are all collectively designated
it as prion diseases I think y'all have
read that term and it's a particular
kind of disease that the infectious
agent isn't a living system not a virus
not a microbe a fungus a protozoan but
rather a protein where it's miss folded
structure nucleates the formation of
more miss folded structure that leads to
the disease so I grew up in England
during the years where there was a lot
of mad cow disease in England and even
though I'm a vegetarian in the US for 30
years I can't give blood in the US
because I lived in England during the
time when there was a lot of mad cow
disease and this can be dormant for a
long long time before it suddenly takes
over so there's a restrictions on blood
donation in certain cases and it's
because it's not something you can treat
with an antibiotic you can treat with an
antiviral it's literally traces of badly
folded protein that can you create the
formation of more badly folded protein
that can lead to the disease's okay
these were there's particular instances
of some of these diseases in in tribes
where there's pretty serious cannibalism
and the eating you're sort of senior
relatives brains was considered to be
something an important act of respect
and there was this transfer of some of
these prion type diseases through
cannibalism as well so eating
contaminated meat be it a cow be it you
know your grandparents whatever it's
something that actually is it's a
serious transmissible disease and it's
really in the situations where it can be
sort of related back to contaminated
meat or one thing but they are
variations in the case of Alzheimer's
where the sequence of proteins may
dictate that they don't fold well or
they're not post translationally
modified properly so they end up as miss
folded proteins so the
are often genetically linked disorders
some of the things like Alzheimer's and
once again remember that goes all the
way back to the DNA which might in some
cases trigger the misfolded disease so
it's a fascinating area and there's a
tremendous amount to be studied because
of the aging population these diseases
are piling up and that we need to
mitigate the the causes of the disease
and find ways for example to slow down
if there are these fibrils of protein
that are misfolded can we maybe inhibit
that formation with some kind of small
molecule inhibitor to mitigate the
symptoms of the disease so it's a very
very active area because almost you know
many many neurological disorders seem to
be coming down to misfolded proteins so
let's move on now to signal so we're
gonna spend two lectures on the
remainder of this lecture plus the next
lecture and what I want to do in this
lecture is introduce you to some of the
paradigms the nuts and bolts the
mechanics of protein signaling and then
in the next lecture I'm gonna show you
examples of how all the characteristics
that we define signaling by get
represented in signaling pathways within
cells I'm gonna give you all the moving
parts and then we'll move forward to see
how the moving parts might function in a
physiological action such as a response
to something particularly scary or as a
trigger to do for the cells to do
something different so let me take you
first of all to a cartoon like image of
a cell and we're going to just take from
the very simplest beginning but then
this topic will get quite quite complex
as you see but I
that's why I think it's important to
reduce the process of protein signaling
down to simple aspects of it that we can
really recognize even in much more
complicated pathways so in protein
cellular signaling this is a complex
system of communication that governs all
basic activities of the cell there are
no cells that don't do signaling
bacterial and eukaryotic cells may do
signaling sites slightly differently but
they still do have an integrated
correlated system that's responsible for
triggering functions of the cell through
a series of discrete steps so protein
signaling can be dissected into three
basic steps where you first of all
receive a signal and we're going to talk
about what that signal is what's the
nature of that signal is small molecule
large molecule where is the signal where
does it hacked then the next step is to
transduce the signal and finally you
have an outcome which is a response so
we're going to talk about each of these
components in order to understand flux
through segment cellular signaling
pathways and how they work to give you a
rapid response to a necessary signal all
right so in this cartoon that's just for
example think about what if we want to
trigger cell division we might have a
signal which is the yellow molecule
small molecule large molecule we'll get
to that later there's a cell here where
on the surface of the cell is a receptor
and that would be the entity that
receives the signal so in the first step
in the process there's a buildup of a
concentration of a signal and it
occupies the receptors on the surface of
the cell and in some cases inside the
cell we'll talk about a bifurcation
there
really a lot of cellular signaling is
dominated by cells coming by signals
coming from outside the cell what
happens upon this binding event is the
transduction if you bind to something on
the outside the cell as a consequence
you might have a change on that
structure if it crosses the membrane you
might have a change on the same molecule
structure that's on the inside of the
cell so that's why it's called
transduction your transducing a soluble
signal from outside binding that signal
to the cell surface receptor and the
cell surface receptor is responding in
some way and there are two principal
ways in which we respond to
extracellular signals and we'll cover
them both the next event that might
happen is through the change that
happens to the intracellular component
of the receptor there might be a change
a binding event another step occur
within the cell and as a function of
that you get a response all right so
it's really thinking it in these three
components is a good way to kind of
dissect out the beginnings of the
complication and then what we'll be able
to do is really start to see what kinds
of molecules come in how are they
received how is the signal transduced
and what's the ultimate outcome with
respect to to a response okay everyone
okay with that all right now this is
what you have to look forward to so we
give you something with three moving
parts and suddenly we show you something
with sort of you know a hundred moving
parts and cell biologists very very
frequently look at these maps of cells
where what they're looking at with each
of these sort of little acronyms or
names all of these are proteins where
they have been mapped out through cell
biology and cellular biochemistry to be
existing in certain components of the
cell and what has also been mapped out
very frequently is who talks to who so
the fact that Jack s might interact with
stat 3 5 and so on so much of this was
work
out through cell biology and
biochemistry and also by genetics so
professor Martin has talked to you about
identifying a player in a complex system
by genetics let's say you have a cell
that fails to divide you might perhaps
screen or divides unevenly or has some
defect in cell division you might be
able to pick out a particular player now
the key thing I want to point out to you
with this cell is what's on the outside
of the cell across and runs across the
membrane and might have the chance the
opportunity to have both an extra
cellular receptor and an intracellular
function and those key proteins are
things like receptor tyrosine kinases
we're going to talk about all of these
in a moment g-protein coupled receptors
and various other cell surface receptors
so all of these anything that spans a
membrane has the opportunity to be an
important component of a signaling
pathway because what you're routinely
trying to do is have your signal
recognized on the outside of the cell by
something that spans the membrane the
signal will back bind to that and then
when you will have an intracellular
response so that's breaking it down
that's why proteins that are made
through the secretory pathway that we
talked about in the last lecture the go
through that endomembrane system and end
up being parked in the plasma membrane
are so important other proteins that
actually gets secreted through that
pathway are also important what do you
think they may be important for let's
say you've made a protein within the
cell it goes through all a system it
doesn't stay parked in the cell cell
membrane it actually gets released from
the cell what might that be doing yeah
exactly
so that endomembrane system that i
described to you that pathway is great
for making receivers and it's great for
making sick
and that's really what can sort of fuel
all the functions of cells okay so in
systems biology you may have heard this
term quite frequently systems biology is
research that helps underline us
understand the underlying structure of
signaling networks so a lot of people
who have common interests in engineering
computational analysis and cell biology
might bring in data to allow them to
make models of cellular systems to
understand flux through signaling
pathways so they may make fundamental
measurements about the concentrations of
some components within the cell and then
try to say okay I know based on
everything I've measured that this is a
dominant pathway for gene regulation and
I could control this pathway by
different by sort of different types of
interactions in this cellular system I
also show you another component which is
the nucleus and when we discuss and
describe specific cell signaling
networks in some cases the signaling
network may involved receiving a signal
undergoing a variety of changes in the
cytoplasm but then a change that
eventually results in a protein going to
the nucleus and oftentimes those
proteins that run into the nucleus are
transcription factors that then trigger
DNA replication or transcription and
then promote activities so this is how
you think about it when you think of
cellular signaling it's really about
what does the signal need to do and what
are the what's the pathway that I follow
to get there so all of those are
membrane proteins so now let's look at
the canonical aspects of signal
transduction so the first and I'm going
to rely on these little cartoons but I
want both in this lecture and the next
to really show you where these recur in
so many systems so so that purpose I
want to talk about the characteristics
so the first critical characteristic
this is a signal and it's specificity so
a signal will be something that comes
from outside of the cell it could be a
hormone that's produced in the
hypothalamus and sent to another organ
but the most important thing about the
signal is that that signal which binds
to a receptor in a cell membrane is
specific for a particular receptor and
the thing and a different signal won't
bind to the same receptor you have to
have faithful signal specificity to
trigger the right function so if it's a
hormone it's got to be the hormone that
you want to trigger the receptor not a
related but different looking structure
if it's a small protein you want it to
be the exact one the binds with high
specificity to receptor so what that
means is if something is binding if a
small molecule is binding to a protein
on the surface of a cell with high
specificity and high affinity it means
that even at a low concentration it will
make that binding contact but all the
other small molecules that are around
won't cross talk into that triggering
that interaction so we have high
specificity and we gain that specificity
through macro molecular interactions
just like the ones we talked about with
in biochemistry so if we have a small
molecule or a protein bind to the
receptor it's making all those hydrogen
bonding electrostatic non covalent types
of interactions with high specificity so
that a low concentration of the signal
molecule is efficient for binding to the
receptor to trigger the function
the next characteristic is amplification
and that's some lines between these guys
now with all the signaling pathways that
you're going to see we're going to be
looking where in a path where you get
amplification very commonly you might
have a response that's just the result
of a single molecule binding a single
receptor but at the end of the day you
might want a large response you might
want to make a lot of ATP or you might
want to replicate all of the genomes so
you need some kind of application where
in a sense you're turning up the volume
on your signal and you need to do that
rapidly so frequently in signaling
pathways you go through a cascade of
reactions where the signal might affect
an enzyme once you make that enzyme
active it might work on many many copies
of another enzyme and then each of those
may work on even more copies so that's
what I mean by amplification we're at
some stage you've generated a molecule
that can result in the Cascade of a
reaction so we often refer to these as
cascade Cascades so if you're
spanish-speaking cascada you want to
think about a waterfall coming from just
a single molecule of water you're
getting a large increase in your signal
as a result of amplification the next
feature or characteristic of signaling
is feedback at the end of the day if
you're signaling I got to make some ATP
I got a run out of the the woods I'm
getting chased at a certain stage you
need to stop all of the process
occurring right so feedback is just a
negative feedback loop that might slow
down some of those steps that are
involved in amplification
so for a pathway you only want the
pathway turned on for a prescribed
amount of time and then you want to be
able to say I'm done with that whole
part I don't need to keep churning
through all those enzymes it's time to
stop that and that usually occurs
through negative feedback and remember
we talked about negative feedback when
we were talking about enzyme catalyzed
pathways so feedback is very often some
kind of negative feedback which
suppresses a series of transformations
perhaps through a product of those
transformations acting as an inhibitor
on an early stem and then finally the
other component of a signaling Network
if you think of signaling networks as
electronic structures you have
integrations so that's a loss the last
characteristic feature let me go back so
that big circuit diagram quickly to show
you an example of integration so if you
look at this signaling pathway all these
signaling steps are not single you just
have a signal come in and you end up for
example in the nucleus but rather other
components may have crosstalk within one
pathway and start either amplifying or
turning down a particular signaling
pathway so these are networks they're
not pathways they're networks that
interact and communicate all to amplify
signals or turn down signals so
integration is an important part of
signaling because you're often dealing
with the integrated function of a number
of pathways to get a particular response
and that actually ends up being one of
the situations where sometimes a
particular enzyme may look like a
perfect target for a therapeutic agent
but if you don't take into account the
integration steps you may be trying to
deal with a sink you're dealing with
your pathway but you're rather dealing
with cross talk with a lot of other
pathways and what often happens in a
cell is there's compensation from other
pathways is everybody following any
questions here about this so what I want
you to think about is that it's just
amazing what is orchestrated to have
even the simplest functions in the cell
how many interacting components there
may be okay
specificity amplification feedback and
integration all right so let's talk
briefly about types of signals and how
we name them where they come from in
order to make sure we're all on the same
page with respect to the language that's
used so now signals may take different
molecular forms they may be small
molecules for example an amino acid or a
phospholipid just something little
alternatively they may be proteins they
may be carbohydrates they might take
different forms in terms of their
molecular structure but we tend to
describe signals by where they come from
so what I've shown you here is a picture
from the book that just describes how we
refer to certain signals so there are
four different terms also crying
Chuckster crying and
I'm gonna just give you a little hint of
how it's to remember these terms okay so
these don't tell you anything about the
molecule they tell you about where it's
come from
all right so an autocrine signal is a
signal that may come from a cell but
it's signaling to itself so it may
produce a component that's released
there so it's producing this through a
secretory pathway it's a release that it
stays in the vicinity of the cell so the
self is self signaling so whenever you
see something auto you just want to say
oh that means it's coming from the same
cell where the signal occurs let's move
to the next one which is paracrine I'm
going to talk about chugs and that's
usually from a nearby cell not a cell
that's in contact definitely a different
cells so paracrine is we would always
call nearby an endocrine is completely
from somewhere else so perhaps coming
through the circulatory system one cell
may release release an endocrine signal
it may weave its way through the
vascular system and then target a cell
so endocrine is always from a distance
and juxtacrine is the only one that's a
little odd it's really from cells that
actually are in contact with each other
so it's not self signaling within a cell
it's not a cell that's nearby but pretty
close it's actually physically making a
contact and so that's the last
terminology there so hopefully I can get
this calcium wave to show you this is
just a video of a of juxtacrine
signaling I just want you to sort of
keep an eye on things it's usually a
cell what you're observing here is a dye
that lights up in the presence of
calcium flux it's called Fuhrer - and so
when you when you stare at these for
long enough what you can notice is that
when one signal will often come from an
adjacent cell right near it so there are
long prosthesis you're not looking at
the entire cell but they're definitely
for example this little duo down here
they keep signaling to each other and
that's a juxtacrine signaling because
the cells are in the contact okay so
that just shows you the difference there
if it was water crying you just have a
single cell responding if it's para
crying they would be at more of a
distance to each other all right I hope
that cut that imagery this is from a
website by the in the Smith lab at
Stanford okay and then the last thing I
want to give you an example there are
many many hormones in the body that
undergo endocrine signaling and so one
example I thought I would tell you about
you all know the insulin is made in the
pancreas it's an important hormone for
regulating glucose levels and it's
actually functions at the muscle level
so insulin is an example of an endocrine
signal because it travels a distance
from where it's made in the body to
where it functions in the body
alright now so we've talked about the
types of signals let's now move the
types of receptors now we cover both the
intracellular and the cell surface
receptors but we really will focus a lot
on the cell surface receptors I just
want to give you a clue that not all
signaling is cell surface so what I've
shown you here is a cartoon where you
see signaling where a signal comes from
outside the cell it goes into the cell
and triggers a change and then the
majority of the time we'll talk about
these receptors that are in the plasma
membrane and they have an outside place
where the signal binds and they trigger
a response inside and it's only very
specific signals that are able to signal
interest in intracellularly that is to
cross the membrane to get inside the
cytoplasm to do the triggering what
kinds of molecules can cross the
membrane easily you we talked about that
before when we talked about getting
across that barrier yeah nonpolar okay
so you can look at a you can stare at a
molecule and if it's very polar or
pretty large it's not going to be able
to sneak through a membrane so something
like a steroid molecule a large greasy
molecule can definitely make that
transition and so those are the only
types of signals that we can really do
inside the cell because they can get
across the cell many many other signals
have to go through this bind to the
outside of a cell and transduce a signal
to the inside of the cell so one very
typical signal that can that can bind to
an intracellular receptor is a steroid
so remember when I talked to you about
these lipid ik molecules things like
testosterone and cortisol these are very
hydrophobic molecules so they literally
can cross from the outside of the cell
without a transporter so for example the
hormone cortisol and when that functions
it just there's an amount of it becomes
available
for example in the bloodstream it
crosses the cell and it binds to an
intracellular receptor once it binds to
that intracellular receptor this
disengages a different kind of chaperone
protein that's keeping it stable once
it's bound it can then go into the
nucleus and trigger trans transcription
so this is the one example of an
intracellular receptor that we'll talk
about I just wanted to show you a little
bit about the steroid receptors these
are molecules that are very these are
macromolecules proteins that are very
have a quite a complex structure but
they can literally and I'll show you the
picture at the beginning of the talk
next time they can literally engulf
these proteins so once the steroid is
bound to that it completely changes
shape and that's what enables the change
for it to be triggered and sent to the
site to the nucleus now the key types of
receptors that we'll focus on though are
the cell surface receptors and there are
three basic classes and molecules that
occur in the plasma membrane that are
critical for cellular signaling they are
the g-protein coupled receptors the
receptor tyrosine kinases and then you
will talk in the lecture 22 about ion
channels and how they perform a receptor
function so the membrane proteins first
of all I want to underscore their
importance 50 percent there they
comprise 50% of drug targets the
receptor tyrosine kinases and the
g-protein coupled receptors a g-protein
coupled receptors have this 7
transmembrane helix structure which
spans a membrane this would be the
outside of the cell and on the inside of
the cell so there's signals going across
there the receptor tyrosine kinase is
our another important type of receptor
they are dimeric proteins that in the
presence of a ligand
dimerize and then cause intracellular
signaling once again they cross the
plasma membrane from the outside to the
cytosol and then lastly there are the
ion channels which also may cross the
plasma membrane and when you think about
these classes of proteins there's a
tremendous amount to be learned with
respect to their functions and they are
so important to understand their their
their physical functions in the body
because they really represent the place
the Nexus where signaling happens in the
cell so I want to briefly show you a
picture of a gpcr it's a seven
transmembrane helix structure you can
see it here
there are about 30% of modern drugs
actually target the GPCRs and here I'm
just going to show you the structure of
a gpcr those are the seven transmembrane
helix YZ if you stretch them out that's
about the width of a membrane that's
typical of a signal that would bind to
or that kind of receptor this is a Kino
chemokine it's a small protein receptor
so you can see that structure and how it
would go from one side of the membrane
to the other in its bound state the
chemokine bounce binds to the seven
transmembrane helix receptor through
kind of a clamping action the magenta is
the chemokine the blue and the green
space filled parts are actually what
holds the chemokine and if you look at
it where the membrane would be you can
see how you can transduce a signal from
one side of the membrane to the other by
the binding of the magenta molecule to
the outside of the cell to those loops
outside the cell that would have a
significant perturbation to the biology
and chemistry of what's going on on the
inside so next class we'll talk about
pathways that are initiated by these
g-protein coupled receptors and what
that terminology means okay
you